JOINING US FOR A REGULARLY
SCHEDULED BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS HEARING FOR TUESDAY
MARCH TWENTY THIRD- JUST A FEW
HOUSEKEEPING ITEMS- AS WE
BEGIN. A WIN COURAGE THE PUBLIC
TO PROVIDE WRITTEN TESTIMONY
BEFORE THE HEARING FIVE IS IN
THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE- PLEASE
KNOW THE ANY WRITTEN TESTIMONY
SUBMITTED TO THE COMMITTEE WILL
BE CONSIDERED PUBLIC COMMENT
AND MAY BE READ AS WELL DUE TO
THE CONTINUED STATE HOME ORDER
WE ARE PRACTICING PHYSICAL
DISTANCE THING HERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM. AND THROUGHOUT
THE CAPITOL BUILDING SO WE ARE
ONLY ABLE TO HAVE A LIMITED
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WATCH AND
PARTICIPATE IN HEARING IN
PERSON WE ALSO REQUIRE THAT
MASS BE WORN AND FISCAL
DISINCENTIVES IN TEN BY ALL
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TESTIFYING WEATHER HERE IN THE
ROOM OR AT. OUR VIDEO VIDEO
CONFERENCING SITE IF YOU DO NOT
HAVE A MASS WE WILL. GLADLY
PROVIDE ONE TO YOU FOR MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC IN THE CHAMBERS
OR HERE IN THE CAPITAL WE CAN
ONLY ACCOMMODATE A MINIMAL
CONTINGENT OF STAFF AND A
LIMITED. NUMBER OF PUBLIC AND
MEDIA SO THAT WE CAN MAINTAIN
SIX FEET OF DEATH DISTANCING.
FOR ANY WITNESSES WISHING TO
CALL AND TO OUR MODERATOR
TELEPHONE SERVICE THROUGH
ANYONE IS STILL YOUNG- WHICH
ANY WITNESS CAN TESTIFY ON A
BILL. THE CALL IN NUMBER FOR
THIS HEARING IS EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN ACCESS CODE TWO FOUR
TWO SIX TWO THREE SEVEN. AGAIN
FOR ANY INDIVIDUALS. MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WISHING TO DIAL IN
THE CALL IN NUMBER FOR THIS
HEARING IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN
SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN. AND THE ACCESS CODE IS.
TWO FOUR TWO SIX TWO THREE
SEVEN. IF YOU'RE CALLING IN
PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND
NOISE SO WE CAN BE SURE TO HEAR
YOU IF YOU HAVE ANY PROBLEMS
WITH THE MODERATED PHONE
SERVICE YOU CAN CALL. OUR
COMMITTEE OFFICE NUMBER AT NINE
ONE SIX THREE ONE NINE. THREE
THREE ZERO ONE AGAIN THAT'S
NINE ONE SIX. THREE ONE NINE
THREE THREE ZERO ONE. AT THE
END OF THE HARING WILL ONLY
RUN THROUGH THE BILLS AT ONE
TIME FOR ADD ONS. WE NORMALLY
RUN THROUGH SEVERAL TIMES OF
THIS IS THAT A DIFFERENT
PROCESS SO IF YOU NEED TO ADD
ON TO. BILLS PLEASE NOTE THIS.
TODAY WE HAVE ASSEMBLY BILL
FOUR NINETY SIX CHEN ASSEMBLY
BILL. SEVEN TWENTY THREE LOW
AND ASSEMBLY BILL ELEVEN OH TWO
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR WHICH
WE TAKE IT UP ONCE A QUORUM IS
ESTABLISHED. IN ORDER TO GET
THROUGH THIS HEARING PLEASE BE
SURE TO SPEAK UP CLEARLY. ALSO
AT THIS POINT IF YOU'RE NOT
VOTING PLEASE SAY SO THAT THE
COMMITTEE FIGURE TIM CAN PLEASE
BE SURE TO RECORD THAT
ACCORDINGLY WELCOME TO NEW
MEMBERS BERMAN DOLLY AND SALAS.
AT THE FIRST ORDER OF BUSINESS
IS A CONTENT CALENDAR AS WELL
AS ADOPTING THE COMMITTEE ROLES
ONCE LIKE A QUORUM IS
ESTABLISHED BUT I CURRENTLY DO
NOT SEE AT A QUORUM. HAS BEEN
ESTABLISHED. SO THEN WE'LL MOVE
ON THEN TO. THE FIRST AUTHOR TO
PRESENT AS WILL BE ACTING AS A
SUB COMMITTEE SO MEMBERS WILL
GO INTO FILE ORDER. AND FOR
MEMBERS THAT ARE NOT CURRENTLY
ON THIS COMMITTEE AND SO WILL
BEGIN WITH FILE ITEM NUMBER
FOUR. AS YOU. DR CORPUS HERE
AND THAT'S ASSEMBLY BILL TWO
FORTY SIX. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
COURT AMERICORPS WELCOME PLEASE
FEEL FREE PRESENT WHENEVER
READY. THANK YOU CHAIR AND
MEMBERS ILLEGAL DUMPING IS IT
ISSUE STATEWIDE AND IMPACTS
PUBLIC SAFETY. PROPERTY PUBLIC
HEALTH AND THE OVERALL QUALITY
OF OUR ENVIRONMENT. LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS ARE REPORTED THAT
DISCARDED CONSTRUCTION
MATERIALS. IS BEING ILLEGALLY
DUMPED IN STREETS ALLEYS AND
OCCUPIED PROPERTY. THERE BEEN
DOCUMENTED INSTANCES IN WHICH
THE CONTRACTORS STATE LICENSE
BOARD LICENSEES HAVEN'T CAUGHT
ILLEGALLY DUMPING CONSTRUCTION
MATERIAL AND DEBRIS AN ATTEMPT
TO CUT CORNERS AND MAXIMIZE
THEIR TOTAL PROFIT.
UNFORTUNATELY THE BOARD CANNOT
DISCIPLINE A LICENSEE FOR
ILLEGALLY DUMPING. BECAUSE
ILLEGAL DUMPING IS NOT A DIRECT
VIOLATION OF THE CURRENT CODE.
AB TWO FOUR SIX WOULD REMEDY
THAT ISSUE BY PROVIDING THE
CONTRACTORS STATE LICENSE BOARD
THE AUTHORITY TO DISCIPLINE
LICENSEES. WHO WERE FOUND
GUILTY OF ILLEGAL DUMPING.
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT IS
MICHAEL J. MASKEY CHIEF OF
LEGISLATIVE BUDGETARY AND
REGULATORY IS AFFAIRS FOR THE
CONTRACTORS STATE LICENSE BOARD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF A GOOD
TO KINDLY ASK YOU TO PAUSE JUST
FOR ONE MOMENT DOCTOR CORBIN
BEFORE WE GET TO TESTIMONY-
FROM MIKE OF WILL ESTABLISH A
QUORUM. HELLO HERE. FLORA YEAR.
ARAMBULA BERMAN BLOOM HERE CHEN
TO. CUNNINGHAM DALY FONG GIPSON
GRAYSON HOLDEN MCCARTY. MEDINA
SALAS WARD. OKAY GIVE ME A STEP
BY STEP AS A QUORUM AND- TO
MIKE PLEASE. NO MORE THAN TWO
MINUTES- FOR TESTIMONY THIS
DOZEN JOY AND I RECOMMENDATION
ON BOTH SIDES OF THE AISLE
THERE'S BEEN A MOTION. AND A
SECOND- MIKE FEEL FREE TO
PRESENT WHATEVER READY. GOOD
MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS- I CAN
ESCAPE TO THE CONTRACTORS STATE
LICENSE BOARD THE BOARD IS
PLEASED TO SPONSOR THIS MEASURE
AS BACK ON THE BENCH WE SHOULD
TO HELP ADDRESS THE ISSUE OF
ILLEGAL DUMPING OF CONSTRUCTION
DEBRIS BY LICENSED CONTRACTORS.
I DON'T HAVE ANYTHING TO ADD TO
THE MEMBERSHIP EDUCATION BUT
I'M CERTAINLY AVAILABLE IN
QUESTION AND WE RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE BUT- THANK. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. ANY ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WISHING
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY
BILL. CHIU FORTY SIX BY DR FOR.
WATER IT WOULD YOU KINDLY OPEN
UP THE LINE. THANK YOU IF YOU'D
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO FOUR SIX IN
THE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR
pTELEPHONE AT THIS TIME. THAT'S
ONE AND THEN ZERO. WE DO HAVE
SEVERAL LINES IN Q. WILL GO TO
THE FIRST LINE IF YOU'RE READY.
BORDERLINE NINETEEN ONE NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
CHAIRMAN BURKE. PRIVILEGE ON
BEHALF OF SEVERAL CLIENTS ALL
BREAK A PHYSICIAN NORTH AMERICA
BUT IT A PASSPORT NATIONAL
ACTION COUNCIL CALIFORNIA
PRODUCT WAS SHIPPED COUNCIL
ELECTIONS YOUR WASTE MANAGEMENT
AUTHORITY IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. WE'LL GO NEXT ONLINE
TWENTY THREE TO THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE RICHARD MARCUSSEN ON
BEHALF OF THE PLUMBING HEATING
COOLING CONTRACTORS OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE WESTERN
ELECTRICAL CONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. IN OUR FINAL
LINE IN QUEUES LINE TWENTY TWO
TWO TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING MEMBERS THIS IS KEPT ON
WITH THE AMERICAN
SUBCONTRACTORS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA. IN FULL SUPPORT OF
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO FORTY SIX
THANK YOU. THERE ARE NO OTHER
LINES IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC HEARING THE
CHAMBERS. WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION SEEING NONE OPERATOR
OTHER ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
AT THIS TIME. IF YOU'D LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB TWO
FORTY SIX ME PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. AGAIN THE COMMANDOS ONE
QUALIFIES ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD. THERE ARE NO
LINES IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OPERATOR.
AND BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
THAT'S BEEN IN MOTION A SECOND
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEEMEMBERS AT THIS TIME
SEEING NONE DR COURT DO YOU
WISH TO CLOSE. YES THANK YOU- I
AM GRATEFUL THAT AB TWO FORTY
SIX IS SUPPORTED BY. THE
CONTRACTORS STATE LICENSE BOARD
THE CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY. AND
HAS NO OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST. YOUR AYE
VOTE ON THIS MEASURE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH DR COURT THIS DOES
ENJOY DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
COMMITTEE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. AB TWO FOUR SIX
QUARTER PAST TWO APPROPRIATIONS
HELLO I. FLORA ALL RIGHT
ARAMBULA BERMAN. HELLO CHEN
CHIU. CUNNINGHAM DALY. FONG
GIPSON HI HOLD UP GRAYSON.
HOLDEN MCCARTY. MEDINA SALAS.
WARD. ELEVEN NICE. LIVE IN EYES
WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH DUCKWORTH. BECAUSE
MOVE ON- TO CONSENT CALENDAR AS
WELL AS DEDUCTION OF THE RULES
IS THERE MOTION. MOTION A
SECOND COMMITTEE SURGERY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. CONSENT CALENDAR
AB FOUR NINE SIX CHEN DO YOU
PASS AB SEVENTY THREE LOW TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS AB
ELEVEN OH TOO LOW TO PASS. LOW
HIGH LOW HIGH FLOOR HIGH FLOOR
I ARAMBULA. ARAMBULA AYE BERMAN.
AND I BLEW. BLOOM AYE CHAN CHEN
HI. CUNNINGHAM DALY DALY AYE
FONG. FONG I GIPSON GIPSON AYE
GRAYSON GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN.
MCCARTY MEDINA SALAS BOARD. HI.
ELEVEN I LIVE IN EYES WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
FIVE WHICH IS ASSEMBLY BILL
ELEVEN THIRTY EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY
WOMAN RUBIO ASSEMBLY ONE RUBIO
THIS DOES ENJOY DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION ON BOTH SIDES OF
THE AISLE PLEASE FEEL FREE TO
PRESENT WHENEVER YOU'RE READY
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
OF THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
PRESENT TODAY ON ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO AND
ACTUALLY LEADING TO ENFORCEMENT
OF UNLICENSED CANNABIS
BUSINESSES AS YOU KNOW THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA BEGAN
ISSUING LICENSES. AT THE
BEGINNING OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN
FOR CANNABIS BUSINESSES TO
OPERATE IN THE STATE TODAY
DESPITE SOME SUCCESS THE SINGLE
BIGGEST ISSUE WITH THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE LEGAL
CANNABIS MARKET IS THAT WE HAVE
A THRIVING EAGLE MARKET
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA ACCORDING
TO RECENT REPORTS ILLEGAL
SELLERS IN CALIFORNIA I'D
NUMBER LEGAL REGULATED
BUSINESSES BY NEARLY THREE TO
ONE THIS REPORT FOUND THAT
WHILE CALIFORNIA CANNABIS
GROWERS COLLECTIVELY PRODUCE
ABOUT NINE MILLION POUNDS OF
CANNABIS PER YEAR THE DEMAND
ILLEGAL CANNABIS MARKET CAN
ONLY SUPPORT ONE POINT EIGHTY
TWO POINT TWO MILLION POUNDS
PER YEAR. THIS LEAVES ABOUT 80%
OF THE CROP EITHER TO BE
DESTROYED OR MAKE ITS WAY TO
THE ELEVEN ILICIC MARKETS. I
PUT THE BOW OF THE ILLEGAL
CANNABIS MARKET AT AROUND EIGHT
POINT SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS PER
YEAR. ALL OF THIS ECONOMIC
ACTIVITY IS BOTH UNTAXED AND
UNREGULATED. IN ADDITION TO
DWINDLING TAX REVENUES THANK
YOU. OF THE UNDERGROUND MARKET
PRESENTS SERIOUS PUBLIC SAFETY
AND PUBLIC HEALTH THREATS TO
OUR COMMUNITIES- MISTER CHAIR
I- THIS IS THE- SECOND TIME
THAT I'VE I'VE TRIED TO THIS
BILL BECAUSE OF THE PANDEMIC I
WE ARE WITHIN A BILL TO DO IT
SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OF SOME OF THE WOMEN RUBIO AND
WE APPRECIATE YOUR TENACITY ON
THIS AS WELL AND THAT KNOWLEDGE
MENT OF YOUR CONTINUATION ON
THIS ISSUE. WE NOW MOVE ON TO
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. OF PLEASE
LIMIT YOUR TEST MANY TO NO MORE
THAN TWO MINUTES IN TOTAL FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT.
OPERATOR PLEASE FEEL FREE TO
OPEN UP THE. LINE FOR SUPPORT
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN. THIS IS
ALBERTO TO RECALL MAYOR FOR THE
UNITED FOOD AND COMMERCIAL
WORKERS. BUT THE SUPPORT AND
SPONSOR LEGISLATION AGAIN WE
ALSO APPRECIATE. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER REVIEWS TO NOTHING ON
THIS ISSUE. AS YOU KNOW UNITED
FOOD AND COMMERCIAL WORKERS
REPRESENTS THE MOST. WORKERS IN
THE CANNABIS INDUSTRY WILL
CONTINUE TO BE EXTREMELY
CONCERNED ABOUT. UNLICENSED
OPERATORS IN THE MARKET PLACE
IS SET THIS SUMMER MENTIONED. A
TWO TO ONE RATIO OF NEARLY NINE
BILLION DOLLARS IN ONE LICENSE
UNTESTED. PRODUCTS IN THE
MARKETPLACE. NOT ONLY NOT ONLY
A CREATING A RISK FOR WORKERS
IN THE PUBLIC BUT ALSO. ACROSS
THE STATE- LITERALLY BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS. WE RESPECTFULLY ASK
ANOTHER THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ADDITIONAL
WITH US IN SUPPORT. AND THERE
CAN MEMBERS ON MAR INTERNET ON
BEHALF OF THE NET CANNOT THE
FOURTEENTH IN THE SPONSORS OF
THE BILL. OUR PROPOSITION SIXTY
FOUR WAS WRITTEN APPROVED
WANTED TO PENALIZE LEGAL
CANNABIS OPERATORS ARE IN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN STATE
APPROVED FIVE FEET ADDITION A
PET. TO BE IMPOSED BY STATE
REGULATORY AGENCIES HOWEVER
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS CONTINUE TO
NOT HAVE TOOLS. TO GO AFTER
THIS IT IS AN ACTIVITY IN THE
MARKET MAKES UP AT LEAST 80% OF
THE MARKET WHICH UNDERMINES ACT
SEPARATE- ORGANIZED LABOR'S
EFFORTS PUBLIC EIGHT WEEK
PUBLIC HEALTH THREAT. AND OF
COURSE I DID HAVE CAUGHT THE
DEEPENING THE DEATH IN THAT
COMMUNITY I WE NEED TO. PUT.
SOME TOOLS IN THE HANDS OF.
LOCAL GOVERNMENT STOP IF IT IS
ACTIVITY WE ASK FOR NIGHT-
THANK YOU MUCH NOW I'M WOULD
YOU OPEN THE LINES FOR MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC WE JUST INTO NAME
PHILLY ONLY IF YOU WERE TO DO
SO. THANK YOU FOR YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB ELEVEN
THIRTY EIGHT ME A PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. AGAIN THE COMMAND ON
YOUR TELEPHONE THIS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. WE DO HVE
SEVERAL LINES IN Q. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. FOR THE FIRST TIME LINE
EIGHTEEN ONE EIGHT YOUR LINE IS.
ARMSTRONG THE POLICY CHAIR FOR
THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
COALITION WE STAND IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE SCHOOL OR THE
BELL. NEXT TO THE NEXT TO
COMMUNIST LINE SIXTEEN ONE SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
MY NAME IS JONATHAN TUCKER I'M
HERE ON BEHALF OF SEVERAL
CANNABIS ALSO STATIONS ALONG
BEACH CANADA COLLECTORS
ASSOCIATION SAN FRANCISCO
CANNABIS RETAILERS ALLIANCE AND
ASSEMBLED. AND SOCIAL EQUITY
LOS ANGELES ALL OF WHOM SUPPORT
AB ELEVEN THIRTY EIGHT AND
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR I.
POD THANK YOU. OUR NEXT THOMAS
FROM LINE TWENTY SEVEN TWO
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
MY NAME IS JEREMY KYLE I'M HERE
IN SUPPORT OF AB ELEVEN THIRTY
EIGHT HERE FROM UNITED CAMPUS
ASSOCIATION AND STRONG SUPPORT.
AT THIS TIME THERE ARE NO OTHER
LINES IN Q. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THE OPERATOR WOULD YOU COMMENT
NOW OPEN UP THE LINES SU
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE LIMIT YOUR TESTIMONY TO
NO MORE THAN TWO MINUTES. CHEN
MEMBERS MY NAME IS DIRECTLY
AFFECTING AND I LET'S STATE.
THE CALIFORNIA STATE DIRECTOR
FOR THAT POLICY ALLIANCE. BPA
IS A LEADING NATIONAL
ORGANIZATION ADVOCATING FOR
KAMPALA THESE CANDIDATES
FINANCE COMPASSION HEALTH AND
HUMAN RIGHTS. I'M HERE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO AT
ELEVEN THIRTY EIGHT WHICH WOULD
HAVE MEANT THE ANTI CO TO
EXPAND YEAH OF COURSE ISN'T THE
MEETING TOOK USE AND MEDICAL
AND MENTAL AND MEDICAL CANNABIS
LICENSING. ALLOW WE AGREE WITH
THE EFFORT TO COME REFINING THE
REGULATORY. TOOL SPREADSHEET AT
THE CANNABIS PROGRAM. WE HAVE
CONCERN WITH THE LEGISLATURE.
AS PRESENTLY DRAFTED FOR OVER
TWENTY FIVE YEARS EPA HAS BEEN
AT THE FOREFRONT OF MARIJUANA
LAW REFORM I SEE FOUR FACTORS
HELPED DRAFT. AND SIGNED UP TO
FIFTEEN IN NINETEEN NINETY SIX
AND TOP BEFORE TWENTY SIXTEEN
WE SUPPORT MERRILL ONE A LOT
THAT REGULATE. MARIJUANA
ACTIVITY AND THAT NO LONGER A
RAFT INCARCERATE
DISENFRANCHISED AND OTHERWISE
FOUR MILLION. PICKING ONLY
PEOPLE OF COLOR WHO ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTED BY
THE WATER TANK WE APPRECIATE
THE INTENT OF AB ELEVEN THIRTY
EIGHT TO PROMOTE COMPLIANCE
LIKE THING. HOWEVER WE REMAIN.
COMMITTED TO THE CONTINUED
IMPLEMENTATION OF PROP SIXTY
FOUR IN A MANNER THAT CREATES A
LOOK BACK IN EQUITABLE MARKET.
WHICH ENSURES THE AVAILABILITY
OF THE FOR MAKING IT A CANNABIS
PRODUCTS FOR CONSUMERS
OPPORTUNITIES FOR INDIVIDUALS
HISTORICALLY OPPRESSED BY
CANNABIS CRIMINALIZATION. AND
PROTECT THE REGULATED MARKET BY
2% LIFE BEING UNLICENSED.
DISTRIBUTION HOW WE REMAIN.
THAT OTHER THIRTY EIGHT IS OPEN.
AND OTHER PRODUCTS. THE BILL
WOULD. MORE NOW INCOME MAKE IN.
WHO NO STAKE IN THE- AND
LICENSE OPERATE SUPPORT TO GET
THE NOT ROLE- TO SIGNAL. SEVEN
THANK. THE THANKS AND CAN LAW
CIVIL. AND IN A TO CRIMINAL
THANK. TAKEN TOGETHER LOW IN
PER DETAINED IN J. LIKE
PRESSURED PLEADING TO A CRIME.
THEY DID NOT THE MATH THAT. I
CAN'T FIND A- SUCH FINE MARGINS.
INDIGENOUS IF ADDED. BY THE
REGULATORY CA. EQUITIES RATHER
RATHER THAN THE TURN ALL THE
FUND TO THE GENERAL FUND. THIS
MAY RESULT IN SOME CASES OF
INEVITABLE AND AGGRESSIVE
ENFORCEMENT EFFORTS TARGETING
COMMUNITIES IN AN EFFORT TO
INCREASE- BUT EIGHTEEN OF
COURSE AND OTHER LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT- BUT AT A TIME.
WHEN WE MUST DO MORE TO THE
DISCIPLINE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
YOU TOO MANY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARE
VERY WOULD YOU CUT ME OPEN UP
THE LINES NOW FOR MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION NAME AN AFFILIATION
ONLY. IF YOU WISH TO DO SO.
THANK YOU WE WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO SB ELEVEN THIRTY
EIGHT. IN A PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE. AGAIN
USING YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD
IT'S ONE FOLLOWED BY. ZERO AND
AT THIS TIME THERE ARE NO LINES
IN Q. THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND SEE NO MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC HERE IN THE CHAMBERS AS
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITE
OPPOSITION. BRING THE
CONVERSATION BACK TO MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE THERE'S BEEN IN
MOTION A SECOND BUT- A QUESTION
OR COMMENT BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WARD THANK YOU CARILLO- HAVE
QUESTION FOR THE AUTHOR ON
THANK YOU FOR INTRODUCING THIS
BILL I. FULLY APPRECIATE THE
ENTIRE NIGHT I WANT TO I DO
SUPPORT THE BILL- BUT I
WONDERED IF THERE MIGHT BE AN
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCE FOR
INDIVIDUALS WHO MAY NOT BE
AWARE THAT A FACILITY OR AN
ENTERPRISE WAS NOT LICENSED- IF
THEY WERE A DELIVERY DRIVER IF
THEY WERE SOMEBODY ELSE IT WAS
JUST A WORKER. WHO WASN'T AWARE
THAT THIS WAS EIGHT ILLEGAL
OPERATION HOW MIGHT THE HOW
MIGHT THIS BE STRENGTHENED TO
PROTECT THEM SO THAT THEY
DIDN'T HAVE TO INCUR A THIRTY
THOUSAND DOLLAR FINE. THANK YOU
FOR THAT QUESTION SO WE KNOW
THAT ARE IN IN THIS CASE IT'S
ARE STRICTLY FOR ADVERTISEMENT
AND PROPERTY OWNERS- WE HAVE
WORKED DILIGENTLY FOR THE LAST
FEW YEARS I- THE BILL ENJOYS-
SUPPORT FROM LABOR UNIONS- LET
ILLEGITIMATE BUSINESS COMMUNITY
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT INCLUDING- THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL SO WE'VEBEEN
WORKING ON THIS BILL FOR
ACTUALLY THREE YEARS- THAT IS
VERY SPECIFIC TO. AIDING AND
ABETTING BUT FOR ADVERTISING
AND PROPERTY OWNERS I KNOW THAT
THE COMING TO WHAT ABOUT THE
PERSON THAT'S WORKING IN THAT
FACILITY IT THE INTENT IS NOT
ABSOLUTELY NOT BACK IT IS VERY
SPECIFIC ABOUT ADVERTISING AND
PROPERTY OWNERS THAT ARE AIDING
AND ABETTING THE LEGAL ON
CANNABIS INDUSTRY. IN THE LAST
FEW YEARS WE'VE SEEN AN UPTAKE
OF- WHAT WE CALL SHADOW-
FACADES SOLD THE BUILDING
MANAGER A BUILDING OWNER LEASES
THIS THIS BUILDING TO A
CANNABIS- INDUSTRY WITHOUT
CHECKING THEIR LICENSE THAT'S
THE PERSON OR THAT IT THE
ENTITY THAT WOULD BE- LIABLE
FOR THE FINE NOT THE PEOPLE
WORKING INSIDE OF IT IT'S
SPECIFIC TO. ADVERTISING AND
PROPERTY OWNERS IN TERMS. OF
AIDING AND ABETTING SO IF YOU
WERE THERE ANY HAVE NO. THEY
WERE NOT GOING TO OR- THE LONG.
IS GOING TO AFTER. THE
EMPLOYEES BECAUSE THEY ARE NOT
RELEASING THE OF THE FACILITY
OR TO- PROVIDING THE
ADVERTISEMENT FOR IT. SO I WE
WERE VERY SPECIFIC AND AGAIN I
APPRECIATE THE QUESTION AND I
APPRECIATE THE COMMENT BY. THE
INTENT IS NOT TO GO AFTER THE
PERSON THAT'S WORKING THERE-
THE INTENT IS TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE- OF ADVERTISEMENT AGENCIES
ARE CLEAR THAT IT'S A
LEGITIMATE BUSINESS AND AGAIN
WHEN YOU LEASE A- BUILDING OR-
A FACILITY THAT IT HAS TO BE
CHECKED OUT THE ARE LEGAL. I
ENTITIES NOT GOING TO ARE NOT
GOING AFTER ANY OF THE
EMPLOYEES IN THIS CASE. OKAY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
AT THIS TIME. SEAMEN ASSEMBLY
WOMAN REVIEW IF YOU WISH TO
CLOSE THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS THANK YOU VERY MUCH THIS
DOES ENJOY DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION FOR THE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AB ELEVEN THIRTY EIGHT RUBIO TO
PASS TO JUST VERY. LOW HI WELL
I FLORA. LARA AYE ARAMBULA
GRANULOCYTE BERMAN BERMAN I
BLOOM. WHEN I CHEN CHEN AYE
CHIU. CUNNINGHAM DALY DALY HI
FONG FONG HI GIPSON GIPSON
GRAYSON GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN.
MCCARTY MEDINA SALAS WARD WARD
HI. ELEVEN NICE LEVELIZED
BELIEVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. COLLEAGUES WILL NOW
GO IN BACK INTO FILE ORDER FOR
MEMBERS NOW ON THIS COMMITTEE
AND WE'RE GOING TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER ONE WHICH IS AB TEN TEN
BY SEVEN MEMBER BERMAN.
BENGALIS I'D LIKE TO START BY
THANKING THE COMMITTEE
CONSULTANT FOR HER WORK ON THE
BET ON THE BILL THE ANALYSIS
SUGGESTS A TECHNICAL AMENDMENT
ON PAGE THREE WHICH I'M HAPPY
TO TAKE CLIMATE SCIENTISTS
AGREE THAT OUR SOCIETY MUST
PREPARE FOR ZERO CARBON FUTURE
NOW WE NEED TO ENSURE THE
DESIGN PROFESSIONALS ARE
PREPARED FOR A NEW KIND OF
REALITY BUT CAR CURRENT
EDUCATION REQUIREMENTS AND
CONTINUING EDUCATION GENERALLY
TREAT ZERO NET CARBON DESIGN IS
OPTIONAL. THEREFORE EIGHTY TEN
TEN WOULD REQUIRE THAT
ARCHITECTS LICENSE BY THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA COMPLETE FIVE
HOURS OF ZERO NET CARBON
CONTINUING EDUCATION FOR TWO
YEAR RENEWAL CYCLE FOR ONGOING
LICENSE OR LICENSURE I WOULD
KNOW THAT THIS BILL SPONSORED
BY THE ARCHITECTURAL
PROFESSIONALS AND THEY'RE
REQUESTING THE ADDITIONAL
CONTINUING EDUCATION
REQUIREMENT RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ASSEMBLY BERMAN THERE'S BEEN A
MOTION AND AS A SECOND LEVEL
NOW OPEN UP THE PUBLIC LINES
FOR PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT
PLEASE LIMIT YOUR TESTIMONY TO
NO MORE THAN TWO MINUTES.
OPERATOR PLEASE OPEN UP THE
LINE. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS IT'S
MIKE BELOW FROM A AYE A
CALIFORNIA. AM I BEING HURT YES.
OKAY THANK YOU- WELL I'M
REPRESENTING- AMERICAN
INSTITUTE OF ARCHITECTS
CALIFORNIA- SPONSOR THE MEASURE
WORDS RESPECTFULLY ASKING FOR
AN AYE VOTE YOU KNOW NET CARBON
ZERO IS REALLY THE DESIGN ISSUE
OF OUR TIME- LOCAL BUILDING
CODES ARE CHANGING THE MODEL
BUILDING CODES ARE CHANGING.
LOCALS ARE IMPOSING
REQUIREMENTS ON- CARBON
EMISSIONS- THE LEGISLATURE AND
GOVERNOR OF MADE IT A PRIORITY
REDUCE GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
BUT IT'S NOT ONLY ABOUT THE
CLIMATE- DESIGN IMPROVEMENTS
WILL ALSO LEAD TO LESS ENERGY
CONSUMPTION THAN OTHER
BENEFITS- CALIFORNIA HAS A VERY
LOW C. E. REQUIREMENT FOR
ARCHITECTS RIGHT NOW IT'S ONLY
FIVE HOURS EVERY TWO YEARS AND
ONLY ON ACCESS ISSUES. SO THIS
IS A MODEST CHANGE A. I. A
CALIFORNIA BELIEVES IN IT SO
STRONGLY THAT THEY'RE COMMITTED
TO OFFERING THE C. E. FOR FREE
TO ALL ARCHITECTS IN CALIFORNIA
MEMBERS OR NOT FOR THE FIRST
RENEWAL CYCLE BUT WE THINK IT'S
A MODEST COMMONSENSE. MEASURE
DESIGNED TO GIVE ARCHITECTS A
RUDIMENTARY. KNOWLEDGE OF NET
CARBON ZERO WITH ME IS MARKED
CHRISTIAN FROM THE ASSOCIATION
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS BUT WE
WOULD ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OPERATOR
ANY ADDITIONAL MEMBERS WISHING
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT. DECLARE BY
RESEARCHERS AT THE SHORTER
VERSIONS THE ME TOOS YES PLEASE.
OKAY THANK YOU TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL AB TEN TEN
YOU MAY PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO AGAIN USING YOUR TELEPHONE
KEYPAD THAT'S ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. AND THERE ARE NO
LINES IN Q. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
CENA ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC ALSO IN THE CHAMBERS
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
THE OPERATOR WOULD YOU CUT ME
OPEN UP THE LINES FOR ANY
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WISHING
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION ON
ASSEMBLY BILL TENTEC. Q. TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF ASSEMBLY
BILL TEN TEN IN THE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO ON YOUR PHONE. AGAIN
USING YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD
THAT'S ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO.
THERE ARE NO LINES IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SEE NO ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC ALSO IN THE CHAMBERS
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
AT THE TIME. OF NOW
CONVERSATIONS FOR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE SEEN NONE THERE'S
BEEN A MOTION AND A SECOND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEANT YOU WISH
TO CLOSE I THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR THAT I THINK THIS IS MY
FIRST TIME PRESENTING A BILL
FROM HERE. AND I JUST COULDN'T
HELP BUT NOTICE HOW
ARCHITECTURALLY BEAUTIFUL. THIS
CHAMBERS IS- BUT WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
IT'S BEAUTIFUL. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. TWENTY CENTER PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. EIGHTY TEN TEN BERMAN
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS HELLO HI LOW AYE
FLORA. FLORA HI ARAMBULA
ARAMBULA AYE BERMAN. MAN I
BLOOM BLOOM AYE CHAN. CHIU
CUNNINGHAM. DALY DALY HI FONG
FONG HI GIPSON GIPSON HI
GRAYSON GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN.
MCCARTY MEDINA SALAS. WARD.
NINE NICE NINE EYES WILL LEAVE
THE ROLE OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS PIES WILL NOW MOVE ON
TO FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE WHICH
IS ASSEMBLY MEMBER FIVE SIXTY
NINE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAYSON
THIS DOES ENJOY DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION BOTH SIDES OF
THE AISLE PLEASE FEEL FREE TO
PRESENT WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN ALONG
WITH MY COLLEAGUE. I DO STAND
IN ALL OF THE ARCHITECTURAL
BEAUTY- OF THIS ROOM. HI GOOD
MORNING- GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS I AM
PLEASED TO PRESENT AB FIVE
SIXTY NINE SPONSORED BY THE
CONTRACTORS STATE LICENSE BOARD
WHICH RAISES THE MAXIMUM CAP ON
CIVIL PENALTY FEES FOR
CONTRACTORS. THE MAXIMUM FREE
FOR MOST VIOLATIONS IS FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS THAT WAS
ESTABLISHED IN TWO THOUSAND
THREE SEVENTEEN YEARS AGO
FIFTEEN THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR
SPECIFIC VIOLATIONS THAT ARE
CONSIDERED MORE CREATURES THAT
WAS ESTABLISHED IN NINETEEN
NINETY TWO TWENTY NINE YEARS
AGO. SO THIS WITH- ELEVATE THAT
THAT CAP BUT ALSO ALONG WITH
THAT IT DOES GIVE THE CSO B.
THE ABILITY TO ISSUE AN
ADMONISHMENT LETTER FOR MORE
THAN ONE VIOLATION WHICH NGUYEN
EDUCATION OR PROOF OF
COMPLIANCE IS DETERMINED TO BE
A BETTER APPROACH THAN A
CITATION I DO HAVE WITH ME A
WITNESS FROM THE CONTRACTORS
STATE LICENSE BOARD. MIKE
GEMINIDS CAN. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. ARE VERY WOULD YOU CAN
OPEN UP THE LINE FOR THE
PRIMARY WITNESS IN SUPPORT
LIMIT YOUR TESTIMONY KILEY TO
NO MORE THAN TWO MINUTES PLEASE
FEEL FREE PERCENT WHENEVER
READY MIKE. GOOD MORNING CHAIR
MEMBERS OF MY COMMITTEE FOR
THAT CONTRACTORS STATE LICENSE
BOARD HI WE APPRECIATE THAT
COMMITTEE CONSIDERING THIS
IMPORTANT MATTER BRINGS. UP
ENFORCEMENT. THAT DAY I DON'T
HAVE ANYTHING TO ADD TO THE
MEMBERSHIP APPLICATION BUT AND
CERTAINLY AVAILABLE TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTION AND WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
EITHER. THANK THANK YOU VERY
MUCH LEAVE THAT CONCLUDES THE
PROP PRIMARY WITNESS IN SUPPORT
OPERATOR WOULD YOU KINDLY OPEN
UP THE LINES FOR ANY ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WISHING
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT. NAME AN
AFFILIATION IF YOU WISH TO DO
SO. THANK YOU TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB FIVE SIX NINE WE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE. KIM THE COMMANDOS
ONES FOLLOWED BY ZERO. WE DO
HAVE A COMMON NAME CUTE COMES
FROM LINE TWENTY THREE TO THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
MR CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS RICHARD
MARCUSSEN FOR THE PLUMBING
HEATING COOLING CONTRACTORS OF
MEASURE THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NO
OTHER LINES ARE IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SENIOR MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
HERE IN THE CHAMBERS TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT NOW GO ON TO MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OPERATOR WOULD
YOU KINDLY OPEN UP THE LINES
FOR ANYONE WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB FIVE
SIX NINE. MAY PRESS ON YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO. TO REPEAT THE
COMMANDERS ONE AND THEN THERE
ARE. AND THERE ARE NO LINES IN
Q. THANK YOU VERY MUCH ENCINO
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION AT THE TIME. BUT
BRING THE CONVERSATION BACK TO
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. SAY NONE HAS
BEEN IN MOTION BY MISTER BLOOM
IN A SECOND BY MR GREAT-
GIPSON. A SIMILAR GRAYSON DO
WISH TO CLOSE. THANK YOU THIS
COMMITTEE PRETTY CONSIDERATION
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH COMMITTEE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AB FIVE SIX NINE GRAYSON TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS LOW HIGH
LOW HIGH FLORA. FLORA I
ARAMBULA ARAMBULA I BERMAN.
BERMAN I BLOOM. BLOOM I CHEN
CHEN AYE CHIU. CUNNINGHAM DALY
DALY HI FONG. FONG I GIPSON
GIPSON HI GRAYSON RECENT HI
HOLDEN. MCCARTY MEDINA. SALAS
SALAS ALL RIGHT LORD. ELEVEN I
SAW ELEVEN EYES WILL LEAVE THE
ROLE OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS. BECAUSE WHEN I MOVE ON
TO FILE ITEM NUMBER SIX WHICH
IS ASSEMBLY BILL ONE ZERO SEVEN
BY SOME MEMBERS SALAS.
SYMPATHIZERS ENJOYED YOU PASS
RECOMMENDATION ON BOTH SIDES
WITH WITH THE MEN'S. PLEASE
FEEL FREE TO PRESENT WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU MR I'D
LIKE TO START BY SAYING THEY'LL
TAKE THE COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS
AND I WANTED TO THANK THE STAFF
FOR ALL THEIR WORK ON THIS
BILL- MEMBERS TODAY PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE OF SEVEN
WHICH EXPANDS AND IMPROVES THE
TEMPORARY LICENSURE PROGRAM FOR
SPOUSES OF ACTIVE DUTY SERVICE
MEMBERS IN CALIFORNIA.
CALIFORNIA HOST OVER SIXTY TWO
THOUSAND ACTIVE DUTY MILITARY
SPOUSES THE HIGHEST POPULATION
IN THE UNITED STATES. MORE THAN
A THIRD OF MILITARY SPOUSES
REQUIRE A PROFESSIONAL LICENSE
FOR THEIR WORK. MILITARY
SPOUSES ARE FAR MORE LIKELY TO
BE UNEMPLOYED AND
UNDEREMPLOYED. WHEN MOVING TO A
NEW STATE AND BURN BURN THROUGH
THEIR SAVINGS ARE FORCED CUT
CORNERS WHILE THEY WAIT. TO
FIND GAINFUL EMPLOYMENT
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU AND THE
WITH THAT I DO HAVE THAT
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT BUT WE CAN
DO THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH A SIMILAR SALAS ALREADY
WOULD YU KINDLY OPEN UP THE
LINES TO PRIMARY WITNESS IN
SUPPORT PLEASE LIMIT YOUR
TESTIMONY TO NO MORE THAN TWO
MINUTES. GOOD MORNING THIS IS
KELLY MAY DEADLIFT WITH THAT
DEPARTMENT DEFENSE- GOOD
MORNING CARILLO IN MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS KELLY
MAY DOUGLAS AS I MENTIONED AND
I AM THAT WE PROTECT SOUTHWEST
REGIONAL LIAISON FOR THE
DEFENSE STATE LIAISON TOPIC
WITHIN THE OFFICE OF THE
SECRETARY OF DEFENSE WE WORK
WITH STATE POLICYMAKERS TO
RESOLVE THE TOP QUALITY OF LIFE
ISSUES FACING MILITARY SERVICE
MEMBERS AND THEIR FAMILIES I'M
HERE TO BEGIN STRONG SUPPORT
FOR THE POLICY CHANGES PROPOSED
WITHIN AB ONE OH SEVEN. AMENDED
ADDRESSING LIKELY RECIPROCITY
AFFORDABILITY ISSUES FOR THE
SOUTH OF THE MILITARY SERVICE
NUMBER HAVE BEEN A PRIORITY FOR
THE DEPARTMENT FOR SEVERAL
YEARS- THE WHITE HOUSE
CURRENTLY IS OUT OF THE PRIOR
TYPING IT DIDN'T LEAVE ISSUES
WITH THE FIRST LADY REGARDING
THAT JOINING FORCES INITIATIVE
FIRST IMPLEMENTED UNDER THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION THAT SEEKS
TO EXPAND EMPLOYMENT AND CAREER
DEVELOPMENT OPPORTUNITIES FOR
MILITARY ABOUT THE AMONG OTHER
QUALITY OF LIFE INITIATIVES-
AND THEN- ASSEMBLY MEMBER SOLID
MENTION MILITARY ABOUT THEIR
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTED BY
THE PACIFIC LIKE THE JERRY
CHOIR MEANT. THAT CAN CAUSE
DELAYS AND GAPS IN EMPLOYMENT-
NOTE THAT 34% OF MILITARY IN
THE WORK FORCE OUR IN LICENSED
PROFESSION WHICH IS HIGHER
THAN- BUT A AVERAGE- AND IT IS
ONLY BE ANNUAL PROSTATE
RELOCATION RIGHT FOR MILITARY
SPOUSES IS ABOUT TEN TIMES
HIGHER THAN THEIR CIVILIAN
COUNTERPARTS- MAINLY BECAUSE
MILITARY ENVIRONMENT CAN BE
RELATIVELY SHORT AND ON AVERAGE
THREE TO FOUR YEARS. IN LINE-
THE CURRENT ENDORSEMENT
PROCESSES FOR REAL LIFE INSURER
ARE OFTEN BURDENSOME AND TIME
CONSUMING- WE DON'T THAT
SIMILAR TO THAT OF THE CIVILIAN
COUNTERPART MOST MILITARY
FAMILIES YOU NEED TO ANY TIME
THOUGH ANY DELAY THE GAP-
FINANCIAL STRAIN FOR MILITARY
FAMILIES ARRIVING IN
CALIFORNIA- I ALSO WANT TO NOTE
THAT MILITARY THOUGHT THAT
APPOINTMENT WAS SIGNIFICANTLY
HIGHER THAN THAT. THE MILLION
WORKFORCE PRIOR TO THE PANDA
MAKE A THE TRANSITION- AND-
FINALLY I JUST WANTED SAY THAT
THAT THE SPENDING IN CALIFORNIA
YOU YEAR TWO THOUSAND WOULD THE
PEOPLE OVER SIX BILLION- AND
MANY OF THE AND STATE- OR THE
FED GRANT THE THEY ARE A- STATE
AND LOCAL. THAT DEMONSTRATE
SUPPORT FROM ABOUT EMPLOYMENT
AND LYFT AND CREDIBILITY- WE
BELIEVE THAT CAN THE PROVISION
THAT LASTED THE LAST SIX YEARS
TO COVER WELL LIKE MEETING
BOARDS IN THE WIN WIN FOR THE
MILITARY. THE BOARD THAT AND
THE PUBLIC THANK YOU FOR TIME
AND I BY THE YOU THINK GIVE ME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SECOND THE
TIME A LOT OF FOR PRIMARY WHEN
ASSISTANCE. OPERATIVE YOU NOW
PLEASE OPEN UP THE LINES FOR
ANY ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT NAY MADE. AN
AFFILIATION IF YOU WISH TO DO
SO. THANK YOU LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB ONE OH SEVEN ME
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD. ONCE AGAIN
NOT TO ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT
THIS TIME. INTERNODE LINES IN
Q. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OPERATORS SEE NO ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN THE
CHAMBERS WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME
OPERATOR PLEASE OPEN UP THE
LINES. THANK YOU COULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB ONE
OH SEVEN ME PRESS ONE THEN THE
ZERO. AGAIN USING YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD THIS ONE
FOLLOWED BY. ZERO AND THERE ARE
NO LINES IN Q. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND SEE NO ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC HERE IN
THE CHAMBERS WISHING TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION BRING THE
CONVERSATION BACK TO MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE FOR ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. SCENE ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS THERE'S
BEEN A MOTION BY MISTER GIPSON
SECOND BY MR FLOOR. MISTER
SALAS D. WAS TO CLOSE
SPECIFICALLY ASKED FOR AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THIS DOES NJOY DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION COMMITTEE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AB ONE OH SEVEN SALAS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO MILITARY VETERANS
AFFAIRS LOW HIGH. LOW FLORA AYE
FULLER AYE ARAMBULA. ARAMBULA
AYE BERMAN. BERMAN I BLOOM.
BLOOM I CHAN CHAN HI TO.
CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM FIVE
DELHI DELHI HI FONG FONG HI
GIPSON GIPSON GRAYSON GRAYSON
AYE HOLDEN. MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE
MEDINA. SALAS SALAS I WARD WARD
HI. FORTY NINE FOURTEEN EYES
WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS COLLEAGUES
READ OUR FINAL BILL
PRESENTATION THIS IS FILE ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN EIGHTY SIX FORTY
SIX. I MYSELF I WILL HAND THIS
OVER TO OUR VICE CHAIR. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR READY WHEN YOU
ARE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
COLLEAGUES- THIS IS A BILL AB
EIGHT SIX FORTY SIX ON
EXPUNGEMENT TO HELP REDUCE
EMPLOYMENT BARRIERS FOR PEOPLE
WITH PREVIOUS CRIMINAL RECORDS
WHO HAVE BEEN REHABILITATED.
AND WHOSE CONVICTION HAS BEEN
DISMISSED EXPUNGED- THROUGH THE
JUDICIAL PROCESS WITH ME AND
SUPPORT IS FORMER ATTORNEY
GENERAL BILL LOCKYER TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT. MODERATED YOU OPEN
UP THE FUNDS FOR SUPPORT. HELLO
THIS IS. BILL WALKER- CANNOT BE
HEARD WE'VE GOT YOU LOUD AND
CLEAR. GOT YOU OKAY THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS
THE MEASURE AS THE ASSEMBLY
MENTIONED THIS- SITUATION IS-
AN INDIVIDUAL THAT HAS A
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL LICENSE
THEY LOSE IT AFTER CONVICTION
OF A CRIME IT COULD BE A
SERIOUS DO YOU AYE OR OTHER
THINGS. AFTER SERVING THEIR
SENTENCE INCLUDING PROBATION A
COURT COULD EXPAND OR DISMISS
SOME OF THOSE CONVICTIONS IN IN
EFFECT EVEN RACING THE CRIMINAL
HISTORY. HOWEVER OUR LICENSING
BOARDS FREQUENTLY MAINTAIN
THOSE RECORDS ON WEBSITES
CONTINUING TO INJURE
REPUTATIONS AND HIBBETT
EMPLOYMENT. THEY ARE CERTAIN
THAT THEY DON'T HAVE THE
AUTHORITY TO CORRECT THOSE
RECORDS OR DO A SIMILAR
DISMISSAL OF THIS MEASURE WOULD
ALLOW FOR THAT TO HAPPEN IT
CREATES A PROCESS TO REMOVE
THAT OUTDATED INFORMATION FROM
THE PUBLIC RECORD. AS SOMEBODY
WHO SERVED IN THE LEGISLATURE
FOR TWENTY FIVE YEARS I HAVE
WATCHED THE GRADUAL TREND TO
REMOVE BARRIERS TO EMPLOYMENT.
THIS IS A WELCOME CONTRIBUTION
TO THAT BIPARTISAN COMMITMENT
HEY RICH SUPPORT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ANYBODY ELSE IN
SUPPORT MODERATE COULD YOU OPEN
THE PHONE LINES. THANK YOU WE
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB
SIX FOUR SIX ME PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD. ONCE AGAIN
NOT AS A ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO.
WE DO HAVE CELL PHONE LINES IN
Q. ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
HI I
APOLOGIZE WE STILL HAVE A FEW
LINES IN Q. WE'RE HAVING
DIFFICULTY CONNECTING WITH THEM
ONE MOMENT PLEASE. NO WORRIES.
GIPSON S. B. GIPSON HE WILL
SPEAK.
I APOLOGIZE FOR THE WAY
WE DO HAVE ACCESS TO ONE OF THE
LINES IS NINE THIRTY SIX THREE
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU CALLS FOR US WITH THE
CALIFORNIA PSYCHOLOGICAL
ASSOCIATIONS WILL SUPPORT OF AB
SIX FOUR SIX THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT OF AB. SIX FORTY SIX.
WE ALSO HAVE LINE THIRTY ONE.
LINE THREE ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MY CAN EDUCATE PRETTY
CONTRACTORS STATE LICENSE BOARD
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME THERE
ARE NO OTHER LINES IN Q. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION ON
THE PHONE LINES FOR AB SIX
FORTY SIX OPPOSITION. THANK IF
YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF AB SIX FOUR SIX
ME PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME AGAIN THAT'S ONE FOLLOWED
BY. ZERO THERE ARE NO LINES IN
Q. THANK YOU VERY MUCH BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE- MISTER
GIBSON. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
MAS WANT TO THANK CHAIRMAN LOW
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL FOR A
LIKE TO BE CONSIDERED AS A
JOINT. RTO ON THIS BILL I THINK
IT MAKES PERFECT SENSE IN TERMS
OF EXPUNGEMENT WE SHOULD NOT
HAVE TO CONTINUE TO PENALIZE-
THESE INDIVIDUALS- PROFESSIONAL
LICENSE IF THEY PAID THEIR DEBT
TO SOCIETY- WE SHOULD BE ABLE
TO WIPE THE SLATE CLEAN I
BELIEVE THIS IS THE- THE
CERTAINLY CONSISTENT WITH
WHERE. THE LEGISLATURE IS GOING
TO IN TERMS OF THE JUSTICE-
ERROR THAT WE IN AND I THINK
IT'S FALLS THE SQUARELY IN LINE
WITH THAT IN THE CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE- MEMBER LOCAL BRING
IT IS FOR IT AND I'LL BE
SUPPORTING TODAY AND WOULD LOVE
TO BE CONSIDERED. TO BE A
PARTNER IN AND ON THIS BILL
MOVING FORWARD THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER GIBSON
MISTER CUNNINGHAM. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I'D LIKE TO THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD AND ALSO IF YOU
ARE TAKING. CO AUTHORS I'D LIKE
TO BE ADDED AND I JUST LIKE TO
SHARE BRIEFLY SOME PERSPECTIVE
FROM THE LEGAL PROCESS INVOLVED
IT'S NOT AN AUTOMATIC THING TO
GET AN EXPUNGEMENT IT'S THE
TECHNICAL TERMS PETITION FOR
DISMISSAL. IF IT'S A
MISDEMEANOR YOU HAVE TO SERVE
OUT YOUR ENTIRE PROBATION
PERIOD BEFORE YOU'RE ELIGIBLE
FOR IT THEN YOU HAVE TO
PETITION THE COURT THE COURT
MUST GRANT IF YOU HAVEN'T.
VIOLATED YOUR PROBATION OR
COMMITTED NEW OFFENSES- BUT
IT'S NOT AUTOMATIC FOR A FELONY
IT GOES BEFORE THE JUDGE THAT
SENTENCED YOU FOR HEARING AND
YOU HAVE TO SHOW WHY IT'S IN
THE INTERESTS OF JUSTICE TO
HAVE A FELONY CONVICTION EITHER
DISMISSED OR REDUCED TO A
MISDEMEANOR AND THEN- DISMISSED
I'VE HANDLED MANY OF THESE
CASES FOR LEGAL CLIENTS OVER
THE YEARS. AND I'D SAY DESPITE
ME TELLING EVERY SINGLE CLIENT
I'VE EVER HAD AND CRIMINAL
DEFENSE CASE HEY THE DAY YOU
GET OFF PROBATION YOU NEED TO
CALL BECAUSE WE GOT A FILE FOR
YOUR PETITION FOR DISMISSAL.
LESS THAN HALF OF THEM DO IT SO
THE PEOPLE THAT WANT TO GET THE
RECORD CLEANED UP ARE MOTIVATED
THEY'VE ALREADY SHOWN THAT THEY
PAID THEIR DEBT TO SOCIETY AND
I THINK THIS IS A GREAT BILL IN
TERMS OF BASIC FAIRNESS I
APPRECIATE YOU BRING IT FORWARD.
THANK YOU MISTER OF ANY ELSE
AND SUPPORT IN THE COMMITTEE.
C. NINE. THAT'S YOUR CALL THE
ROLL. AB SIX FOUR SIX HELLO TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS LOW AYE
LOW AYE FLORA AYE FULLER AYE
ARAMBULA ARAMBULA AYE BERMAN.
BERMAN I PLAN LAMB I CHEN CHEN
AYE CHIU CHU HI CUNNINGHAM
CUNNINGHAM I DAILY DAILY HI
FONG. FONG HI GIPSON IT'S AN
AYE GRAYSON GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN
HOLDEN HI MCCARTY MCCARTY HI
MEDINA. SALAS SALAS FIVE WARD
WARD HI. SIXTY NINE. THERMISTOR
TO THE BILL THAT WAS SIXTY
VOTES WILL PASS IT BACK TO YOU.
THANK YOU COLLEAGUES THAT.
CONCLUDES THE BILLS HAVE BEEN
PRESENTED BUT WE'LL GO THROUGH
FILE ORDER. AGAIN NOW- TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE HAVE THE
APPROPRIATE ADD ONS LET'S BEGIN
WITH A CONSENT CALENDAR AND ALL
ALSO THE- ADOPTION OF COMMITTEE
RULES. CONSENT CALENDAR AB FOUR
NINE SIX CHEN DO YOU PASS AB
SEVENTY THREE LOW TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS AB ELEVEN OH TOO
LOW TO PASS. GEN. CHEN AYE CHIU.
Q. HI. CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM I.
HOLDEN HOLDEN HI MCCARTY
MCCARTY AYE MEDINA. MEDINA HI
SALAS SALAS HI. EIGHTY NINE.
EIGHTEEN EYES OF THOSE BILLS
ARE OUT OF CONSENT IS THAT THE
CONTENT COUNTERS ADOPTED IN
COMMITTEE RULES ARE APPROVED
NOW THEN TO FILE ORDER AND THE
BEGINNING WITH A FILE ITEM
NUMBER ONE WHICH IS A. B. TEN
TEN BY SOME A MEMBER BERMAN AND
THE- IS A- DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION. AB TEN TEN
BERMAN TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CHEN. CHEN AYE
CHIU. CHU HI CUNNINGHAM
CUNNINGHAM I. HOLDEN HOLDEN I
MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE MEDINA
MEDINA I SALAS SALAS I WARD
WORD I. SEVENTY NINE SEVENTEEN
EYES THE BILL IS OUT FILE ITEM
NUMBER THREE. AB FIVE SIXTY
NINE BY SOME IMMIGRATION DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION. AB FIVE
SIX NINE GRAYSON TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS CHIU. CHIU AYE
CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM HI
GRAYSON. I APOLOGIZE HOLDEN
HOLDEN I. MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE
MEDINA MEDINA HI WARD. HI.
EIGHTY NINE EIGHTEENS EYES THE
BILL IS OUT FILE ITEM NUMBER
FOUR AB TWO FORTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION.
AB TWO FOUR SIX
COURT TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS.
QIU QIU HI CUNNINGHAM
CUNNINGHAM HI. HOLDEN HOLDEN HI
MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE MEDINA
MEDINA HI SALAS SALAS I.
SEVENTEEN ICE. SEVENTY NINE THE
BILL IS OUT FILE ITEM NUMBER
FIVE A. B. ELEVEN THIRTY EIGHT
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER RUBIO DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION. AB ELEVEN
THIRTY EIGHT RUBIO TO PASS TO
JUDICIARY. CHU CHU AYE
CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM HI HOLDEN
HOLDEN HI MCCARTY MCCARTY HI
MEDINA MEDINA HI SALAS SALAS HI.
SEVENTY NINE SEVENTEEN IS THE
BILL IS OUT FILE ITEM NUMBER
SIX AB ONE ZERO SEVEN BY SOME
OR SALAS DO PASS RECOMMENDATION.
AB ONE OH SEVEN SALAS DE PASS
AS AMENDED TO MILITARY AND
VETERANS AFFAIRS QIU. QIU HI
HOLDEN. HOLDEN HI MEDINA MEDINA
HI. SEVENTY NINE SEVENTEEN IS
THE BILL IS OUT FINALLY FILE
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN AB IS SIX
FORTY SIX LOW DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION. AB SIX FOUR SIX
LOW TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS.
ALL MEMBERS HAVE BEEN CALLED.
ASSEMBLY AT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MEDINA FIVE MEDINA HI. SEVENTY
NINE SEVENTEEN IS THE BILL IS
OUT BECAUSE WILL LEAVE THE ROLE
OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL TWO MINUTES
FOR ADDITIONAL ADD ONS.
I THINK
THE FACT. THE TWENTY ABOUT THE-
LOADINGVIDEO. YEAH HERE WHAT
DOES I KNOW TOLD ME BEFORE YOU
AND STUFF. RIGHT HELLO JUST
TOTALLY RESPECTIVELY. TIME WITH
OVER THE PHONE OKAY BOTH SIDES
HAVE BETTER HEALTH- DISCO SO
TAKE. OKAY OKAY YEAH. IT'S A
LOT OF THE- GOOD FOR YOU KNOW
FOR THE RIGHTEOUS ANGER THAT
PEOPLE GO THROUGH THE- YEAH
MARKET. AFFIRMATIVE ROTATED
BETWEEN OUR GROUPS. YEAH I
GUESS THE RIVER WAS A BATTLE
REYES AND THEN SHE LOOKED AT
THE WALMART.
BECAUSE WE ARE
TURNED.